[Music]
let's watch uh why don't we watch some
videos let's watch kim k house tour oh
god let's do it this is a new house tour
yeah february 12 2022.
but my dad it's so cool he used to work
at mca so it's on his letterhead and it
says kimberly i cut your hair on april
11 1988 and there's my hair
should i get a new house because she's
not anymore hey vogue it's kim we're
here in my home once again a few things
have been updated i've like filled it up
with some amazing art and all my
favorite things wait a posit
is this the same house that she lived
with
kanye in so she said welcome back now
here's like basically here's what it
looks like without him in my life no
because he has the crazy like you know
um art installation home
yeah it was all white
yeah like the rooms are all rounded and
it's crazy as well so i think this is a
home that's maybe featured like it's
been previously featured maybe she lived
in it
you know
on keeping up the kardashians and stuff
how many homes do they have quite a lot
dude
i've been in that in that neighborhood
before did i tell you that no yeah i
went in there one time you sure yeah
i'm not lying dude
jesus [ __ ] christ i'm just never
going to let you have it
no i did and i drove by kris jenner
her house was in there i don't know if
she still lives there or not but there
was security just like standing on the
street outside she probably wasn't in
there she probably just made that makes
them stand there because she can yeah
probably honestly probably yeah
and i saw drake's house oh nice did you
pee on it
i didn't pee on it no
no [ __ ] i should have yeah yeah is that
drake's house i have a feeling this is
about to be really sad
objects of affection we're in my family
kitchen and everything in my house is
really that is oh so it is the home
that's pretty fire
is this not the house
animal looks less i find that there's so
much chaos out in the world that when i
come home i want it to be just really
quiet and i want everything to feel
calming every time i leave
the gated community it's chaos yeah do
you know there's [ __ ] homeless people
other people drive cars it's really
annoying i know
the sound of a highway alone it's like
ugh oh my god and then when i try to go
get food it's like other people are
eating around me it's just like that's
not what i want when i eat and they eat
like at like pained express you've been
there yeah oh my oh chaos such chaos
they like get in
they get in line for food it's really
weird so
yeah it just it kind of just stresses me
out so you know when i get here i just
wanted to be quiet
no one like
like dirty or ugly or just you know
i like everything to be pretty because
like when you go out there it's just so
many ugly people yeah just ugh
so i like it to be pretty at my house
yeah i'm quiet they're so loud and
they're ugly ugh it's like because
they're ugly their voices seem to be
louder yeah and they're ugly voices too
that's the thing they sound good voices
yeah it hurts my ears yeah like the
traffic yeah
rooms one is pink one is purple one is
blue one is dinosaurs it's like each kid
can have their full style and taste in
their bedroom
the people
well the way she describes these rooms
it's like her kids live in like a
dementia facility
and have so much fun but in the main
house
i really like the calmness and
shockingly
four kids hasn't messed up my cream
house
cream
cream
come on man see that's what i was
looking for crazy that is the great
title for like a [ __ ] only fan's
house yo welcome to the cream house
[Laughter]
i'm lana this is mia and you're at the
cream house
no it would just be
a bunch of [ __ ] boys cream house yeah
for sure what's up previously from the
sway house yeah what's up i was in the
stroke house now we've come together and
created the cream house so pull up if
you want to get creamed yeah
five of them like
[ __ ] jizzy ass like logo cream house
so the first object of my affection is
my daughter north's paintings and
drawings she's a really really good
artist this dancer loves to paint she
did this about two years ago she does
like little paintings for me like this
wolf
she
recently
north stayed home and had yeah that's
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a really good painting from a
child dude yeah yeah that's not a red
flag yeah at all
was that after the travis scott fest oh
nice man nice sorry nice
hovid so this is her drawing that she
did
in her room it's a charcoal
maybe that was just her emo mood so i
loved
your daughter literally drew an image of
like her soul leaving her body
in a that dude that was like a [ __ ]
a24
like opening
it really it is like are you kidding
this is the beginning of the next 824
film [ __ ] some kid named damian yeah
you know omen 5. and it's [ __ ] this
like under like they pull it with the
dinosaur and the [ __ ] happy wolf and
then just that
just don't know he's being emo or
something
she's just having an emo moment
like the circles around the face how is
she drawing yeah just like
north sweetie it's time for bed no bro
she wasn't looking at the paper she was
like
[Laughter]
north sweetie talking a reverse
oh she's just practicing her dutch yeah
north
yeah just
turns 180. bro that is hilarious man are
you kidding me maybe that was just her
emo mood so i love seeing like the
personality and the moods and everything
that she goes through and is feeling
it's really been an amazing hobby of
hers yeah just had to get a shot over
from the back walking down the hallway
that is a crazy ass hallway oh
it's yeah it's also a crazy ass yeah
no but i just like that is like a dude
that's a scene out of dune yeah are you
kidding yeah
how do you know i feel like you're going
to kill a goat every time you walk down
that
[Music]
yeah big ass door so now we're in the
sitting room to my bedroom the sitting
room
you're just coming here to see where do
you sit
i'm in the sitting room yeah okay yeah
i don't sit in any other room in my
house except for the sitting room yeah
just the sitting room dude
it's really cozy it's like a place where
i love to just sit and have tea and
write letters to my kids and why don't
you just go talk to them
i love to sit down and write letters to
my kids i don't know where they are i
hate talking to them directly
they live with their nannies yeah
somewhere else yeah just somewhere i
make the most epic baby books for them
so i'm gonna show you guys
anyone knows me they know that i love
to scrapbook so that my kids can have
the most amazing memories this is north
but i have them for each kid i have all
of their little hospital
details i've written out you know mom
and dad's history
her first vogue shoot
everyone that visited her yeah super i
remember my book my baby book yeah my
first vogue shoot was in there too yeah
it's lame as hell
you just cut out squares and put them on
a piece of paper i guarantee we got
scrapbooks like people listening to this
right now got scrapbooks from sixth
grade that go harder than this yeah
i'm not doing that for my [ __ ] kid
yeah no i'm saying i'll you know i'll
vlog them yeah you know yeah
yeah daddy
dad cry again where's my baby books i
want to see my baby books from when i
was like a little baby look at this nine
minute video of you [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i did this live stream yo what is up
youtube
i did this live stream once where i
wiped your ass
i changed your diaper on live it was
sick i saved it